28 year old Brian coburger in his first
court appearance a man accused of a
quadruple murder
[Music]
death and or imprisonment for life do
you understand yes
he showed no emotion there was no plea
and no bail
it was on November the 13th that the
most gruesome of discoveries was made at
this home on King Road Moscow Idaho four
young students from the local University
stabbed to death
Maddie Mogan Zana kamodel Kaley
gonzalves and Ethan Chapin
it had been a typical Saturday night for
them two of the victims had been at a
bar the other two had a party they'd
come home here to the house police
believe they were murdered sometime
after 4am investigators searched for a
suspect and the murder weapon for weeks
publicly at least investigators said
they had no leads it was a case that
dominated the news with no clues no
weapon no suspect now an unsealed legal
document reveals that they did have
evidence they had part of a murder
weapon they had DNA and a suspect the
document the justification for the
arrest which would come eventually shows
that a tan leather knife sheath was
found lying on the bed a surviving
housemate saw an intruder a figure clad
in black and a mask security cameras
picked up voices or a whimper followed
by a loud thud a car was seen and
tracked by its license plate multiple
sightings of suspect vehicle one behind
the scenes cross-referencing of Records
provided a phone number the handset was
tracked proving say police the suspect's
proximity DNA was recovered from the
trash of the suspect's family home in
Pennsylvania it provided a link with DNA
on the knife sheath a breakthrough
investigators believed and on December
the 30th the suspect was arrested on the
other side of the country from the
murders he's alleged to have committed
is this your car
it turned out he'd been stopped by
traffic police as he'd driven from west
to east with his father investigators
were closing in on him
outside Court a brief statement on
behalf of the families it's obviously an
emotional time for the family seeing the
defendant for the first time
this is the beginning of the criminal
justice system and the family will be
here for the Long Haul
Brian coburger will appear again and
enter a plea on January the 12th Mark
Stone Sky News